- All right, so let's finish
up with something hopeful
for Dog Appreciation Month.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
It's sad to think about
it that thousands of dogs
are euthanized every year here in LA.
It's truly a crisis
and that's why it's such a comfort to know
that there are people like
sisters Ina and Isabelle
doing their part to save
as many pups as they can.
They opened Bubbles Dog Rescue
a year ago, and to date,
they've saved hundreds of dogs.
We have them on the
line right now watching
on NBC 4 Los Angeles.
Everybody say hello to Inna and Isabelle.
Hello, ladies.
- Hi.
- Hi!
- Hi, Kelly.
- Hello. So, how did this all get started?
- Yeah, well, we'd loved
dogs our whole lives
and then when we found out
about the shelter crisis in LA
and the surrounding counties,
we just knew we had to help.
So we started our own rescue.
Often we pull dogs from shelters
hours or even minutes before euthanasia.
We also remove dogs from abusive homes
and we rescue dogs from
the streets of Mexico
and we provide full
vetting and neuter spay.
- That's amazing.
So, Isabelle, this is all
run by volunteers, right?
- Yeah, that's right.
We're actually an all
women run volunteer team,
and none of us get paid.
We all have full-time jobs.
We depend on public donations
and the general public to save more dogs.
In the last year since we started,
we've saved over 300 lives
and currently, we have 63
dogs available for adoption.
The more dogs we get adopted,
the more we can save.
So, that's why it's so
important to spread awareness
about the shelter crisis
and also about our rescue.
We absolutely love our community
and hope everyone can join in
supporting Bubbles Dog Rescue.
- Aw, that's incredible guys.
Thank you so much, Inna and Isabelle.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(bell dings)
- [Inna And Isabelle] Yay!
- Oh, absolutely.
Girls, that's not all though.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like y'all.
So, they're gonna be writing
Bubbles Dog Rescue a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheers)
- Oh my gosh. Thank you!
- Absolutely, ladies. Way to go.
I love what you're doing, keep it up.
Thank you to all of our
guests this hour, actually,
Nicole Byer, Toheeb
Jimoh, Danielle Kartes,
Krista and Lori.
Y'all have a great day.
If it's not, try and change it.